bonjour à tous merci d'être avec nous on
est en direct avec nathalie et limaces
plus qu'en dirait que vous êtes avec
nous sur le plateau bonjour madame la
ministre vous êtes secrétaire d'état
auprès du ministre de l'éducation
nationale de la jeunesse et des sports
chargé de l'éducation prioritaire plus
précisément on va parler de la rentrée
évidemment des détecteurs de co2 qui se
font attendre des du port du masque et
des tests et de ce nouveau protocole
sanitaire tout d'abord ce qui s'est
passé à l'assemblée nationale hier soir
l'examen du projet de loi qui vise à
installer ce se passe sanitaires se
parlent actional pardon à partir du du
15 janvier l'examen du texte a été
suspendu
l'oeil par un vote des députés de
l'opposition qui s'est passé c'est un
gros cafouillage c'est une claque au
gouvernement c'est un camouflet non
c'est pas un cafouillage vous savez moi
avant d'être membre du gouvernement j'ai
été député pendant trois ans donc j'ai
siégé à l'assemblée et j'ai vu ça
plusieurs fois on dit que en tout cas
les oppositions disent qu'il y à un nous
font un procès en déni de démocratie n'y
a pas de démocratie dans ce pays depuis
qu'il ya la crise sanitaire etc c'est la
douzième fois c'est le douzième texte
depuis le début de la pandémie première
chose deuxièmement les députés sont
libres ils font ce qu'ils veulent la
preuve ils ont décidé de suspendre et de
reporter eh bien écoutez libre à eux et
puis de toute façon on va avancer dans
le texte ils n'ont pas voulu siéger
cette musique peut le comprendre je
pourrais penser
la résidence gros est amer
abbas a on verra en tout cas il y aura
une conférence des présidents ce matin
qui va fixer un nouveau calendrier et
les députés vont siéger et c'est vrai
qu'ils se sont couchés un peu plus tôt
et hier soir mais je pense qu'ils vont
passer leur week end à paris mais ça
veut dire que le pass vaccinale sera
repoussé sa sera pas mis en place à
partir du 15 janvier a priori non il
faut voir encore une fois ce qui va être
décidé ce matin et le nouveau calendrier
à l'assemblée nationale parce qu'après
je vous rappelle il faut que ça parte au
sénat donc effectivement d'ailleurs ça
devait être examiné aujourd'hui en
séance au sénat en tout cas en
commission donc ça va être légèrement
décalée mais je pense qu'il ya pas
vraiment de surprise sur l'issue et que
le pass vaccinale bien sûr sera votée
voilà c'est un petit jeu de des
oppositions jeu je siégeais au moment où
on a étudié le texte sur les retraites
je vous rappelle qu'il y avait des
amendements qui pleuvaient des
sous-amendements etc on connaît ces
techniques voilà la preuve en tout cas
c'est que les députés sont libres et que
la vie démocratique et bien là présente
elle bat son plein dans notre pays et je
crois que c'est l'essentiel la rentrée
scolaire hier nouveau protocole
sanitaire quand ya un cas dans une
classe quand y'a qu'à dans une classe il
ya trois tests en quatre jours pour
chaque élève bon on dit que c'est un peu
l'usiné à gaz comment ça s'est passé
hier là la doctrine a évolué on a cette
histoire de deux tests faits par les
familles c'est déjà en place depuis le
début du mois de décembre je rappelle
que précédemment quand y avait un cas
dans une place ont fermé la classe
ensuite on a dit quand il ya un cas dans
une classe ont fait tester tous les
élèves les élèves négatif reviennent
évidemment les élèves politiques restent
isolés oui aujourd'hui on évolue on a
fait évoluer bien sûr les règles on ne
cesse de s'adapter de s'ajuster et en
effet notre objectif c'est de ne pas
fermer les écoles ça vous l'avez bien
compris j'en vois bien pris en compte
est massivement les élèves pour garder
les crèches ouvertes mais ce que est ce
que le vrai système en fait c'est pas le
système d avec les profs qui se
débrouille un peu comme ils peuvent dans
la réalité elles système d on fait
tester tout le monde de façon
extrêmement régulière et puis encore une
fois si je regarde un petit peu en
arrière rappelez vous il ya quelques
mois que disaient les oppositions mais
c'est très simple on n'a qu'à faire
tester les élèves massivement c'est vrai
bien voilà c'est exactement ce que l'on
fait aujourd'hui alors je ne vous dis
pas que c'est simple pour les élèves
pour les familles et même pour les
professeurs je le reconnais c'est moi je
suis mère de famille mon fils est rentré
hier il est positif voilà bah je vais
faire la série de tests comme tout le
monde pour les professeurs évidemment
c'est compliqué parce qu'il faut
vérifier puisque une fois qu'on a fait
le test antigénique ou pcr il y a deux
autos tester donc il faut une
attestation des familles etc donc oui
c'est compliqué mais qu'est ce qu'on
veut qu'est ce qu'on veut pour nos
élèves est ce qu'on veut les confiner
est-ce qu'on veut fermer les écoles bien
voilà est-ce qu'on joue ce jeu là qui
est un petit peu difficile mais au final
tout le monde reste en classe jérôme
béglé en quoi est-ce que le nom de
professeurs éventuellement contaminés
par la copie tout cas contacts
pourraient venir perturber le
les cours normaux fermer des classes ou
créer un gros absentéisme ascenseurs ne
sont pas autrement que les autres et il
n'y a
pas à ce jour on aura un état à la fin
de la semaine comme chaque semaine on a
des remontées académique et on sera
précisément pour les élèves et pour les
professeurs et nombre de classes fermées
ça c'est certain il ya des professeurs
malades oui mais des professeurs qui ne
peuvent pas venir parce qu'ils ont un
enfant malade donc il faut les remplacer
alors on va renforcer les présences des
personnels remplaçants et puis il ya une
ultime solution encore qui est de mettre
aussi certaines classes en distance yale
on l'a fait tout au long de la crise
malheureusement on a un peu d'expérience
et donc on peut encore faire ça aussi
pour permettre cette continuité
pédagogique madame la ministre il ya eu
aussi une question qui revient très
souvent les détecteurs de co2 on en
parle on en parle on les voit pas alors
le ministère a débloqué 20 millions
d'euros et rassemble 1 j'avais j'avais
un mr le maire de viry châtillon pardon
les élus ont également pas vu le début
d'un euro le parlement a voté 20
millions d'euros ça c'est clair c'est la
contribution de l'état parce que dans le
principe c'est capteur de co2 c'est
d'abord la responsabilité des
collectivités les mairies pour les
écoles les conseils départementaux pour
les collèges et bien sûr les conseils
régionaux pour les lycées je rappelle au
passage qui a un lycée sur deux équipés
de capteurs de co2 alors vous savez
qu'il ya une candidate lr qui est
candidate à la présidentielle qui est
aussi présidente de région mais déjà
faut qu'elle commence par les équipes et
ensuite dans la pratique il y a eu une
note qui a été passé la semaine dernière
encore la campagne préfet au recteur
justement pour le process donc c'est
très simple si les collectivités veulent
équiper des classes et d'ailleurs c'est
pas toutes les classes ça n'est pas
nécessaire on peut haïr et ses classes
parfois c'est plus compliqué donc si les
collectivités 10 là où là il faut des
capteurs on s'adresse au préfet on
s'adresse aux recteurs et il y à un
financement de l'état qui a été voté à
hauteur de 20 millions d'euros
nathalie et limaces secrétaire d'état
auprès du ministre de l'éducation
nationale merci beaucoup d'inconnues ce
matin sur le plateau de la halde